Water
Earth
Fire
Air
Welcome back everyone is going to be my new
Avatar The Last Airbender Netflix video Netflix
finally confirmed a bunch of details. The
main cast will break it all down. If you're
brand-new to the channel, be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos. Also talk about what
Mike and Bryan have said about the new Avatar
The Last Airbender movie that they're working
on in the other new avatar shows that they're
doing is all that separate from what's happening
with the Netflix Avatar The Last Airbender
series. There is a a lot of avatar coming
in the next several years. Queue the avatar
version of that Rick and Morty 100 years rant
which starting with the main cast for the
Netflix Avatar The Last Airbender series saying
is being played by Gordon Cormier you may
remember him from Netflix is lost in space,
some of these actors that I'll be talking
about or from other Netflix shows they were
like to keep in the family he's been posting
a bunch of videos of himself practicing martial
arts recently. So Zuko other character that
they absolutely have to nail is being played
by Dallas Liu who will be seeing in the upcoming
marvel shang chi in the legend of the 10 rings
movie. I thought they might be playing a version
of young, shang chi, but IMDb doesn't officially
list to he's playing in the movie Qatar is
being played by an actress named Kiawentiio
whose name on probably mispronouncing she's
also coming from another Netflix series called
and with an easy I'm not really familiar with
any of her work in the only other cast member
that they've announced right now, so far is
Socko he's being played by Ian Ousley who's
from another Netflix show 13 reasons why the
biggest ones they have not announced yet for
season one are I wrote Fire Lord Ozai Admiral
Zhao and Roku. Yes Azula and Suki big characters.
But as Azula doesn't really become a huge
character till season 2 which is also why
you won't hear them talking about toph till
they start working on season to let people
forget that she is really become part of team
avatar till season to the last we heard their
supposed to start filming episodes this November.
That date might stick so that means will probably
be seeing episodes around this time next year
or the fall little later they take longer
in postproduction. Because of all the bending
special effects that the do Netflix is going
to keep posting promos and teasers as they
continue to announce new characters and going
to official production uncle. I will pie be
one of the next people that they announce
but we probably won't get a full trailer with
finish special effects to like Spring next
year or later it's going to be a long time
because it takes forever to finish special
effects. If you want a really good example
of what a live action Avatar The Last Airbender's
can look like you have too much PTSD or your
therapist is telling you not to go back and
watch that original last Airbender movie.
There have been a lot of good fan films like
there was in agony Chi fan film does a pretty
good example of what it might look like. But
I was he they don't have the budget the Netflix
will have to do the special effects for their
bending abilities. The showrunner issued an
official statement that Netflix tweeted out
saying will be expanding and growing the world
and there will be a few surprises for existing
fans and those new to the tail I'll explain
what that means in a second. But throughout
the process are byword has been authenticity
to the story to the characters to the cultural
influences. I also knew what I didn't want
to do. I didn't want to change things for
the sake of change. I didn't want to modernize
the story or twisted to fit current trends
egg is not going to be a gritty antihero.
Qatar is not going to get curtain bangs when
he says he's not going to modernize the show.
He literally means he's not going to do Avatar
The Last Airbender but is it took place in
present day and he's not chasing trends by
just changing the nature of the characters
or their depiction to make the show feel like
every other shows on TV right now. The real
big thing, though, was to cast the characters
more authentically to the races in the cultural
influences that they're based on in the original
series when the showrunner said that there
expanding and growing the world. That's mostly
because the original series was only 61 episodes.
They were each just a little over 20 minutes
long. The Netflix series because live action
will be closer to like 4050 minute episodes
and they want 8 to 10 episodes per season,
minimum and for it to run 4 to 5 seasons.
Potentially, so they only did the scenes that
were in the original episodes that would only
last them for three seasons of about 10 episodes
of the negative change the end of the original
series. Sozin's Comet that still going to
be the end point of the series. They will
be pushing past that. But when he says expanding
and growing things there will be surprises
for fans of the original series. That means
are going to include a lot of extra new scenes
that were not in the original series and usually
what that works out to is like conversations
the characters have just run on for longer
characters have all kinds of scenes together.
They didn't appear in the original episodes
like that would be. Sometimes in episodes
where members of team avatar just would not
interact with each other because they be focusing
on different parts of team avatar more there
was in a ton of Admiral Zhao outside of when
he was interacting with the main characters.
Imagine him getting more scenes during season
one. Because he is kind of the main villain
of season one stuff like that is a little
easier to do this when they get the full team
avatar in season two. But you get the idea.
My assumption right now without more information
just based on the way it sounds like they
want to paste the story out the season one
finale will probably be the events of the
winter solstice with and going to the fire
nation Temple and learning from Roku what
his mission is how he needs to learn to bend
all the other elements in control the avatar
state before the end of the summer when Susan's
comic comes back granting all the fire Bender's
even greater power supercharging them making
fire Lord owes I almost unstoppable for anyone.
But the avatar is a solid cliffhanger to and
season one on unless they just completely
want to speedrun the plot which hopefully
they don't like if he says there expanding
and growing things a lot it means there stretching
the story out a lot. You probably remember
last year Mike and Bryan also announced that
they were leaving that Netflix Avatar The
Last Airbender series because of creative
differences. I have some theories about why
that was. But the biggest reason we found
out later in the year was because Viacom and
Nickelodeon gave them a dump truck of money
to open their own studio called avatar studios
and make whatever avatar movies and TV shows
they wanted. This is the clip of them talking
about the 20 plus years worth of avatar TV
shows and content that they have planned.
Is there anything you can tell us about avatar
studios and and future of where things are
going so you might have sort of mapped out
a very ambitious multitiered feels like a
big octopus said looking at how we can go
deeper into this big, rich, largely untapped
history and future in the world. So there
I their ideas that we've been excited about
for a long time that were finally getting
to really dive into and then there's things
that were just figuring out just getting really
excited about. We want each of these projects
that have its own feeling its own tone and
look in and so it will all feel true to the
avatar world, but they will all be very different
expressions of it so it will really deepen
it and expand it. So yeah there is all there
is for and explore a bunch of stuff were fans
of you to to yeah and if we have make all
the stuff you guys are speak podcasting for
about the next 20 years or so. I think we've
talked about that. Like this is amazing were
reporting on the avatar verse. If you haven't
heard it Dante Basco Prince Zuko himself and
Janet Varney the voice of Korra are doing
avatar podcasts where they basically recap
the events of the original Avatar The Last
Airbender series and then though the legend
of core after that they also bring on the
other casting crew members from the original
avatar show and from Korra to talk to them
their mostly focusing on the original avatar
series right now though, but they announced
the first new project that they're doing this
first new avatar project is going to be an
animated theatrical film bill release it in
theaters and it will begin production later
this year. This is Mike and Bryan's official
statement. So Bryan posted this on his Instagram.
He said break his back and Nickelodeon in
a big way with a bunch of emoji's Mike and
I are heading up a new studio dedicated to
expanding the avatar verse so that's him saying
that they're craving their own version of
the marvel cinematic universe with the avatar
characters basically like were expanding mythology
in a huge way with a bunch of new series in
a bunch new movies with in the were kind of
only thinking about the next couple years.
I can't wait to see that next series they're
thinking about the next 15 to 20 years of
avatar like some of you will all go on to
have children and grandchildren who will be
watching brand-new avatar series, then their
statement just goes on to say it's hard to
believe it's been 19 years since we created
Avatar The Last Airbender but even after all
this time there still so many stories and
so many time periods in Ames world that we
are eager to bring to life, meaning that a
lot of the new series will just jump around
in the timeline in the past and probably in
the future as well. We are fortunate to have
an ever-growing community of passionate fans
that enjoys exploring the avatar verse is
much as we do. Just for example, last year
when Avatar The Last Airbender episodes hit
Netflix it was the most popular animated series
around the world of any kind it be all the
brand-new animation it was that popular in
this is in 2020. So you have all these brand-new
kids in people that are discovering the series
after all this time, so it is more popular
than ever right now, then they go on to say
and with this new avatar studios venture we
have an unparalleled opportunity to develop
our franchise and its storytelling on a vast
scale in a myriad of exciting ways and mediums
that just means the can it continue to do
all the books in the comics alongside all
the brand-new series and movies and shorts
that they're going to be doing, but they'll
announce more details about what all these
new projects going to be later this year's
of course will do videos for that in other
bonus videos, leave all your requests and
your big questions in the comments below.
If you weren't around for my channel way back
in the day I did episode videos for all of
Korra and I have a bunch of Avatar The Last
Airbender videos his welts will put links
for all that stuff in the description. I got
a couple new trailer videos that I'm working
on you can click here for my full marvel what
if episode one video and click here for my
post credit scene video. Thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe and I'll see
you guys next video!